that's the thing that you just shot
gonna sell you on Instagram yeah I wrote
a short and directed it and basically
what I liked about it was it was not a
story that had anything to do with me or
what people know of my comedy my friend
Moni
about is a Middle Eastern actor in LA
and he goes in for terrorist roles
literally every week and he's from
Sacramento LA and all he does is going
for NCSI he blows up the helicopter so
we talked about it and we wrote a story
about what his life is in LA so it's
like entourage with Middle Easterners
that's a great yeah it's funny yeah I
got some good heart it's a great idea
and it looks unbelievable and honestly
it's really not anything to do with me I
had the great cinematographer ivan
Rodriguez and looks like we spent
$300,000 on it you didn't but I'm
psyched man it's like are you having a
screening I'd love to see it I mean we
would love singin link I'll just send it
over you have it it's all ready to go
yeah yeah I agree I'm being real though
ya know we're doing the film festival
circuit now but yeah I hit the code in
you know how they drive it so I go
what's the color I put the code in I'll
seal yawns I uploaded it to a site
called ru porn he said to dick pic and I
just yeah I tagged it at the beginning
now do you still live in that one house
where you do the barbecues out yes house
yeah that's probably the house that I'm
gonna stay in I don't I don't I'm a
creature of habit I'm ready to just
settle down in that spot we're looking
for a house now and um because I've been
here in this thing for 12 years 13 more
you've been here 12 yeah I did like I
thought when you know when you're single
and you know when this thing was brand
new when I don't buy that and I live out
my days but we have a big family now we
have cats and dogs and I want to buy a
house and we've been looking we put some
bids in but the thing is is your house
though I love his house because you did
those barbecues there's a fourth of
Joe's anymore right
I do yeah I didn't do it last year comes
away I don't know if I can do it this
year because I'm away doing gigs I
almost took it personally no but I was
your own
even if even if I don't invite you
you're invited I know I think one of
them I did to do that but uh those
barbecues were are [ __ ] amazing they
did remind me of kind of the Dublin's is
where you see people that you don't
normally see like at your collective
club or and you see guys like Marc Maron
wear shorts which is [ __ ] weird
sandals he were saying can I get
philosophical about this location you
live in though this 12 years how long
have you been actively looking for a new
place two years okay your your this is
one man's opinion so don't kill the two
cents okay you're keeping yourself here
you're keeping yourself in a confined
space and some of its security and
comfort and because you know you you're
familiar if you put a plant in a small
pot it grows about this big if you put a
plant in a huge vat it [ __ ] goes up
to the ceiling not to move and you need
to expand so you can expand as a thinker
and as a person two years come on so
short
[Laughter]
according to their where they're in case
where their cages so that's yeah height
thing it's just okay look your size by
the way I like it say that okay I like
your size by the way your fun side but
you're right I did I listed the last
month we've bid it for two houses good
they're still on the right because we
did a lot we you know I have a certain
budget and I went a little higher so we
have cartoon you know and then we're
looking but I think we're in the next
couple of months we will be moving and I
want to grow I want to grow I had fear a
big wide-open space
though right the farce go ahead I like
that we've been I don't know it sounds
terrible uses him you know cuz we're so
we're so close and attached at the hip
and we've made it work here that I even
he's like we need to get a king-sized
bed but no no no you know double forever
so cuz I need that closeness and they I
think I still have a fear he's probably
closest it's not like you're gonna move
to the Serengeti you can be like oh
we're in a yeah you know it's just
you'll you'll be closer you'll be closer
yeah even with more space around you
because you'll be happier you'll be more
content and and yeah you know how I said
we're pressure players yeah when I
lucked that apartment and bought my
house I couldn't afford the house that I
was and I wasn't quite ready to have
that house at that time I've gone
through all this crap with my business
manager all of it I couldn't afford that
house but I forced myself to getting in
a situation that I had to survive why
keep it Whitney did the same thing
companies yeah Whitney Cummings before
she did 2 broke girls and before she was
on her own show Whitney right this is
during the Chelsea Lately days she was
I'm buying this house and it was so much
money and I go oh you're doing that he
goes no I'm not doing that good but I
feel like I can do it I'm gonna force
myself to do it
sure so that's yeah that's you know yeah
I believe what you think oh she lived on
my believes we get a 6 million dollar
house
[Laughter]
[Music]